today's topic there's yet another update
with the pj washington brittany renner
story you saw that [ __ ]
apparently if you guys aren't aware i'm
going to give you guys a brief rundown
britney renner is an ig thought who's
been involved with a lot of celebrities
amidst the fact that she wants to fleece
nba players blah blah blah she gets the
young nba player who's 20 years old uh
even i know she's posted videos about
what she's going to do to young
millionaire when she catches them after
she catch the young man slipping she
gets a baby by him you know be a
millionaire now she got him on for child
support she got a child by him cool pj
washington brittany renner split and
then bj washington
pj washington has been sharing pictures
of himself getting close to another
instagram model after a split from
brittany renner
and this is what we told you guys in the
first video we done told y'all life's
going to give you lessons if you don't
learn you're doomed to repeat it now you
guys might say but you don't know that
this other uh
ig model who's had kids by other famous
people broke up with him it's good we
don't know and you know what maybe i
don't know but here's also what i do
know
if you always go and pull from the same
types of women
in order to find your dating matches
don't get mad when you get the same type
of results all right these women are
based off of making money and getting
clout you being a famous person you got
to pick your maids smarter but hey what
do i know
good luck to you
what do you want to say
what do you want me to say it's like
when i saw that i was like when i saw
that [ __ ] i was like
dude
he's for the streets
all of that [ __ ]
you're gonna go back to that
you know what and it made me think
sometimes like
it's crazy it's like dysfunctionality is
normal the whole concept of b that's
normal to like baby moms and [ __ ] like
that it's like that's they're if it
happens it happens but i feel like
there's some people that's just thriving
to that to go that's their goal when
when you're rich rich i could get it but
i mean he's rich rich but it's still
stupid
because here's the thing you can say
when you're rich rich
money disappears very fast especially
for young athletes oh yeah so many of
them end up broke and having to get
regular jobs even though they've made
millions why because they don't know how
to manage their money they don't have
good people around them maybe they get
with the wrong instagram model who
fleeces them for their money so you know
it just takes one season ending injury
and he could be out for the rest of his
life
so it's not about whether you have money
or not you gotta be smart about these
things you gotta pick your mates
properly
bigger with more money
men than him
have been ruined by women before true by
picking the wrong people in your life
true
let me ask you this yeah go ahead okay
because this girl is also older than him
more you know more established than him
yeah at one point
does it stop being this whole like
victim-blaming narrative at what point
does this man have agency over his
decisions oh wait
you have to stop with a victim blaming
the minute she posted videos of what she
was about to do to players
online that there was no victim blaming
there
you have to understand what a victim
blaming is like and what victim blaming
does and who can actually victim blame
you know what i mean like this this [ __ ]
right right there no it's not victim
blaming nowhere when you broadcast it
like that you just see you just
broadcast it to the world
what you do what you would do
and you end up doing it wait what what
are we talking about where victim blame
where
victim name what
who who
[ __ ] what
[ __ ] who
[ __ ]
yeah that's a good try another track by
um jay-z and i don't know which one
um
yeah no there was no
victim blaming nowhere nowhere was there
a victim let me and then you double down
[ __ ] you you two scoop cupid
[ __ ] you double deer
it's like if i tell you yo careful the
salsa is very picante and then you dip
and then it's picante and now your mouth
on fire and then you double dip
so
now hold on hold on hold on we don't i'm
not saying we i don't know this broad
i don't know the new girl so i can't say
that she's for sure gonna do that but
you're fishing in the same pool go ahead
so
we've spoken before about dick
discipline right
you gotta control your dick can't be out
here just slanging it everywhere right
[ __ ] who for the streets are always
out there just [ __ ] left right and
center traditionally lead miserable
lives why because they can't control
their urges right they'll drop friends
they'll drop meetings they'll drop
business opportunities to go [ __ ] people
are like that
you have the other end of the spectrum
all right these are recall like they
they need relationship discipline okay
people who just date the same kind of
people over and over and then constantly
complain about their bad results
you you know them don't have to be rich
either i know a bunch of broke
[ __ ] who take the same type of
dudes and then whine and piss and moan
about it every time afterwards right
they broadcast their relationships every
time wake up the next day pookie hit me
all right cool
sent him to jail then you get with ray
ray right afterwards ray ray hit me
[ __ ]
that's his best friend
they used to beat women together
and you dated both of them
you know then i'm not saying it's
acceptable send them to jail don't get
me wrong they're still criminals go
ahead but at some point at which point
do you
you know gotta take accountability for
some of those choices if you're really
unhappy with the outcomes you're getting
if it's a lot of the same patterns
that's the weird thing how do you date
the same person often oh that's normal
because we have a type
people people have type and sometimes
it's not even type it's really
preferences but sometimes you have to
understand what your preferences are
based into and sometimes your
preferences are amazing to talk [ __ ]
there's some toxic [ __ ] around you and
you know there's things just such as
toxicity toxicity and
um
dysfunctionality is
somewhat normal around you when you grow
up well your choices are going to be
based on that
and then you're going to choose a
[ __ ] or you're going to have a
lack of something and you're going to
try to have to recuperate that lack in
somewhere else but you try to overdo it
and this is just basic psychology that's
what happens people are basing their
normal into dysfunctionality in
trash so
you know you have to imagine right
someone has a giant ig account
400 000 followers dudes constantly
thirst rapid famous or not you know
you're already setting yourself up for
failure and like instability why am i
saying that because traditionally people
who have a vast amount of options are
far less likely to be
loyal than people who don't
that's also going to be a fact you know
why she getting with you specifically
because you're a baller you got money
but guess what people got more money
than you
there's people got more money just like
that spine insurgent from nyc found out
later on that his his home girl was
escorting the whole time they were
married
why because some ceo came through and
picked up that miss connecticut okay
did he that's what happened
it's a different story but anyways all
this to say
i know what story you talking about if
you pick up girls who are traditionally
clown chasers
are you going to be surprised when
someone with a bigger clout than you
snatches her out
but that's besides the point
but it it's not though because how you
get these ladies and what they're
projecting and what they're going for
you know the daily daily life has an
effect
sorry but if you start dating a playboy
bunny
okay and she going on tour
sorry
you might get playboy ladies are you
dating a man and he's going on on tour
with his band and they're popular
good luck
what you want me to tell you
so some of y'all be pulling from folks
who
don't give you the best return on
investment and then you're surprised
when your [ __ ] crashes like a bad
bitcoin
you know what i'm saying bars no this is
like
you make bad investments so you [ __ ]
surprise you're surprised with your [ __ ]
crashes like bad bitcoin yeah like a bad
cryptocurrency that [ __ ] on the shirt
put that [ __ ] on her shirt goddamn
that's bars i didn't think it was that
good personally it was all right if i
got a good ball i'll let everybody know
yeah all right that was like a no but
number one like a five out of ten it was
a six five six six and a half you know
what rate it below in the comments six
it was not at four this video was way
longer than what i expected yeah at the
end of the day you know listen i hope it
works out between them both of them but
make better
don't be mad when your [ __ ] crashes like
a bad bitcoin
[ __ ] [ __ ] that bad cryptocurrency
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter it matters to me oh
okay
it matters to me damn it i get it i give
it i give it a seven all right well
listen i gave it a five let us know what
you guys think in the comments below
that's it for today's video leave a like
[Music]
i